Now let's discuss how we will design
a server that requires some persistent support using
this idea of a persistent virtual memory.
So this is the virtual address space of
the server. And note that, not the entire address space of the server needs to
be persistent because as the developer, the
subsystem designer knows what data structures in his
design need persistence. So for instance if you
take a concrete example like a file server design.
Then the inode data structures, which may be
living on the disk are the things that the
file system designer would want to make sure
that they're persistent. So if an I node data
structure, let's say M1 is mapped into a portion
of the virtual address space, then it is manipulation
of M1 in particular, updates to M1 that
needs to be reflected in the backing store.
These data structures, M1, M2 and so on,
are data structures, which are in memory versions
of persistent data structures that live on the
disk. We will call the collection of data
structures that need to be persistent on the
disk as a data segment. And a application
may choose to use multiple data segments. That
corresponds to persistent objects that it needs to
manipulate in the course of its execution. So
these data structures M1, M2 and so on, are
the persistent metadata that have an on disk
copy, as well as an in-memory version. Whereas all
the other stuff in the virtual address space
of the server are normal code and data structures.
So in terms of flexibility for a server
design, it would make sense to allow an application
to create as many data segments as it needs in order to support what it needs to
do in it's design. So what we need to do is to allow an application to map
an external data segment. By external data segment what
we mean is that there's a data segment that
is external to the virtual memory living on
the persistent medium, in this case a disk,
and the application is going to map this external
data segment to selected portions of its address
space. What we will help the application do
is to explicitly map the regions of the
virtual address space to data segments that live on the disk. And as I said to
allow flexibility, the application designer may choose
to have multiple external data segments and
map these different data segments to different
portions of the virtual address space. Or in
other words, the application completely manages their
own persistence needs, and all that we
are providing is the ability to specify
external data segments to back persistent data structures
that we're going to manipulate in memory. So
what the application would do is, at
startup, it'll map these external data segments
to selected portions of its virtual address space
in order to create the in-memory versions
of the data structures it needs to manipulate
during the course of its execution. And
the mapping between this virtual memory space and
the external data segment is also one to
one. That is there is no overlap of external
data segments in terms of occupancy within the
virtual address space and this makes the design of
a reliable virtual memory, that much more simpler.
So simplicity is the key in the design so
that it is easy to use, flexible, and
performing. And those are the goals that the authors
of reliable virtual memory set out to accomplish.
And just as mapping is done at startup at
any point of time, the application can choose
to unmap a portion of the virtual address space
that is mapped to the external data segments.
And we will see later on that opportune moments
for doing this unmapping would be when no
commits are pending. For these in memory data structures,
and external representation of those data structures
in data segments living on the disk.